son anti-russe agressif
politiciens l'Occident a franchi toutes les limites, nous
Nous entendons constamment des menaces contre nos
certains pays de notre peuple
politiciens irresponsables à l'ouest
ne parler que des projets d'organisation
fournitures en Ukraine de longue distance
des systèmes d'armes offensifs qui
permettra à d'autres de frapper la Crimée
régions de Russie telles terroristes
grèves, y compris celles utilisant
Des armes occidentales sont déjà infligées à
colonies frontalières
Région de Belgorod Koursk OTAN
effectue des reconnaissances dans tout le sud
Russie
à Washington DC accroupi droit
poussent Kyiv à transférer l'armée
les actions sur notre territoire ne cachent plus
dit que la Russie devrait être
vaincu par tous les moyens sur le champ de bataille
suivie d'une privation de pouvoir politique
économique culturel en général
toute souveraineté avec pleine
pillant notre pays, l'entrée est allée et
chantage nucléaire il ne s'agit pas seulement
bombardements de la région de Zaporozhye encouragés par l'Occident
centrale nucléaire
un certain aîné
représentants des principaux États de l'OTAN sur
possibilités et applicabilité
contre la Russie armes de destruction massive
armes nucléaires
ceux qui se permettent de telles déclarations dans
concernant la Russie, je tiens à vous rappeler que notre
le pays a également divers
moyen de destruction A pour particulier
composants et plus modernes que ceux
pays de l'OTAN et en cas de menace sur le territoire
l'intégrité de notre pays à protéger
Russie de notre peuple, nous avons certainement
nous utilisons tous disponibles dans notre
disposition des fonds
ce n'est pas du bluff, mais ceux qui essaient
nous faire chanter avec des armes nucléaires
sachez que la rose des vents peut se retourner
et dans leur direction je considère qu'il est nécessaire
soutenir la proposition du ministère
défense et état-major
tenue en Fédération de Russie
mobilisation partielle
Je le répète, nous parlons de partiel
mobilisation, c'est-à-dire la conscription militaire
seuls les citoyens seront soumis au service
qui sont actuellement en
réserve et, surtout, ceux qui sont passés
service dans les rangs des forces armées
certains registres militaires
spécialités et expérience pertinente
appelé au service militaire
envoi en pièces vous liant
la commande subira des
formation militaire basée sur l'expérience
opération militaire spéciale
Décret de mobilisation partielle signé
dans le cadre de la résolution des principales tâches de protection
Donbass Nos troupes basées sur des plans et
décisions du ministère de la Défense et
état-major pour la stratégie générale
actions libérées des néo-nazis et
territoires importants de Kherson et
Régions de Zaporizhzhya un certain nombre de certains
d'autres domaines de la manière la plus difficile
le régime de répression a été renforcé tout au long
L'Ukraine vis-à-vis de ses propres
citoyens établis immédiatement après
coup d'état armé
politique d'intimidation terreur violence
prend un effrayant de plus en plus massif
nous voulons souligner les formes barbares
nous savons que la plupart des gens qui vivent sur
territoires libérés des néo-nazis
Et ce sont avant tout des terres historiques
La nouvelle Russie ne veut pas être sous le joug
régime néo-nazi, nous ne pouvons que
nous n'avons aucun droit moral de donner
nos proches à la merci du bourreau
nous ne pouvons que répondre à leurs sincères
le désir de déterminer votre propre vie
parlements des républiques populaires du Donbass a
également civilo-militaire et administration
Régions de Kherson et Zaporozhye
a décidé de réaliser
référendums sur l'avenir de ces territoires
ne s'est pas tourné vers la Russie avec une demande
nous ferons de notre mieux pour soutenir une telle démarche
fournir un environnement sûr pour
organiser des référendums pour
les gens pouvaient exprimer leur volonté
décision concernant son avenir qu'il prendra
la majorité des habitants de Donetsk et Louhansk
républiques populaires de Zaporozhye et
Région de Kherson que nous soutenons